[Musik]
Rosen aus Stahl heißt die Hymne für
Chinas Fußballfrauen sie besingt ihre
Anmut und ihre Stärke
frauenfußball ist beliebter denn je in
der Volksrepublik
die Zahl der Jugend die eine schlechte
Meinung von fußballspielenden Mädchen
haben wird immer kleiner
die Gesellschaft in rasantem Wandel
immer mehr junge Frauen durchbrechen
traditionelle Rollenbilder
in meiner Heimat sagen sie dass ich
längst verheiratet sein und Kinder haben
sollte aber ich werde erstmal weiter
studieren
doch auch in China gehen Frauen durch
die Hölle trotz Überwachungskameras über
Gewalt an Frauen zu sprechen vielerorts
ein Tabu Beweisvideos werden zensiert
gelöscht
Frauenrechtsaktivistinnen immer öfter
bedroht und eingeschüchtert
sie fragen ob wir überhaupt registriert
sind und sagen sie werden uns bei der
Polizei anzeigen
Frauen die Fußball spielen Frauen die
Selbstvertrauen gewinnen und Frauen die
für mehr Gleichberechtigung Verhaftungen
riskieren wie verändert sich das
Frauenbild in China
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Training bei 39 Grad
untypisch war sie und ihre
Mitspielerinnen hier machen sie tragen
Shorts und T-Shirts und bekommen
Sommerbräune
[Musik]
oh mein Gott hier auf dem Spielfeld
kümmern wir uns nicht um weiße Haut klar
im Alltag sind wir schon schön als
bewusst wir tragen alle Make-up
[Musik]
weiße makellose Haut das ist das
Schönheitsideal in China vor allem bei
Frauen viele tragen im Sommer deshalb
Schutzkleidung und verhüllen Körper und
Gesicht
[Musik]
und ihre Freundinnen haben damit
gebrochen
wie auch ihr großes Idol Chinas
Frauenfußball Nationalmannschaft 9 mal
asienmeisterinnen einmal
vize-weltmeisterinnen Silber bei Olympia
jetzt WM in Australien und Neuseeland
das Männer-Team hat die Staatsführung
enttäuscht mit schlechten Leistungen und
korruptions-skandalen
jetzt gibt es einen Förderplan für die
Frauen
2031 WM im eigenen Land spätestens vier
Jahre darauf ist der Titelgewinn
vorgesehen
[Musik]
wir haben alle früheren
frauenfußball-weltmeisterschaften
angeschaut ich habe unser Nationalteam
schwitzen und hart arbeiten gesehen das
hat mich sehr berührt ich bewundere sie
so sehr
ist an der Universität zum Fußball
gekommen und sie ist 23 Jahre alt und
studiert in Peking Transportwesen
Schwerpunkt autonomes fahren an der Uni
suchte sie einen Ausgleich zu den vielen
Stunden in denen sie lernen muss
angeboten wurde dort Fußball ganz nach
Plan der Kommunistischen Partei die
frauenfußballbegeisterung im Land zu
steigern doch die Trainingsmethoden an
Jungs Hochschule waren traditionell
erzählt sie Härte Drill Leistung und der
Sieg standen im Mittelpunkt
an ihre Grenzen und begann an sich zu
zweifeln
das Fußball Umfeld an der Hochschule war
wirklich sehr schlecht
ich hatte ein geringes Selbstwertgefühl
ich hielt mich für nichts Besonderes für
einen ganz normalen durchschnittlichen
Menschen ich glaubte auch nicht dass ich
jemand bin der von anderen wahrgenommen
wird
doch mit den veralteten
Trainingsmethoden wollte sie sich nicht
abfinden und suchte einen neuen Trainer
gefunden hat sie töbeln seine
Philosophie für den Infinity Verein ist
etwas Neues im leistungsorientierten
China sie lautet schlicht habt Spaß
es geht hier nicht um den Sieg oder
darum höher schneller stärker zu sein
sondern darum etwas für sich und seine
Persönlichkeit zu tun
die Methode voll auf ihr Trainer sagt
sie ist von einem eher melancholischen
dünnen Mädchen zu einer starken
teamkaptain geworden
wenn es früher im Studentenwohnheim zu
Konflikten und Auseinandersetzungen mit
unseren Kommilitonen kam haben meine
Freundinnen und ich oft nichts gesagt
wir haben im Stillen gelitten
ich habe das Gefühl dass ich jetzt viel
selbstbewusster in meinem Leben geworden
bin ich habe meine eigenen Ideen und
kann sie auch ausdrücken
nach dem Training treffen wir die
Spielerinnen wieder und gehen zusammen
essen es gibt eine Delikatesse scharfen
situationeneintopf Fisch Fleisch und
Innereien wir sprechen über die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft und darüber
das Frauenteams auf der ganzen Welt
immer noch benachteiligt werden
die chinesische Männer
Nationalmannschaft fliegt zum Beispiel
First Class zu ihren spielen die Frauen
economy sie verdienen auch deutlich
weniger als die Männer
obwohl die Menschen in China das Gefühl
haben dass Männer und Frauen heute
gleichberechtigt sind gibt es in allen
Bereichen subtile Diskriminierung von
Frauen
sei es bei der Arbeitssuche oder beim
Fußballspielen
auch bei unseren chinesischen
Schriftzeichen das Zeichen für
eifersucht hat das Symbol für Frau an
der Seite
das Frauen in China hatte die gleichen
Bildungschancen haben wie Männer und
auch genauso zur Arbeit gehen war und
ist im Kommunismus gewollt und wird
gefördert doch im Staat der alles
kontrollieren will läuft längst nicht
alles wie erhofft
[Musik]
das junge Frauen heute über Themen wie
Gleichberechtigung diskutieren darauf
ist verlieren stolz
die 60-Jährige kämpft seit vielen
Jahrzehnten für Frauenrechte in China
doch ihre Arbeit wird immer gefährlicher
sie erzählt von Anfeindungen und
Drohungen per Brief und online
ich habe das Gefühl ich muss mich
rechtfertigen für meine Arbeit
auch unsere Finanzierung ist schwierig
2017 hat China ein Gesetz verabschiedet
danach dürfen wir keine Gelder von
internationalen nicht
Regierungsorganisationen mehr annehmen
die uns früher unterstützt haben
Familien leitet ein Netzwerk das Frauen
unterstützt die Opfer von Gewalt wurden
ihre hilfe-
die 24 Stunden lang erreichbar ist
[Musik]
brutalste Schläge und Tritte gegen eine
Frau auf offener Straße einen Streit
zwischen einem Ehepaar ist eskaliert
szenen wie diese gibt es immer wieder
Männer sehen zu niemand greift ein diese
Videos wurden zwar in sozialen Medien
gepostet und öffentlich gemacht doch
dort werden sie fast immer sofort
zensiert ausradiert das Volk soll sie
nicht zu Gesicht bekommen
in China gibt es zwar Gesetze die Frauen
vor Gewalt schützen doch sie bleiben oft
zahnlose Tiger sagt von mir Gewalt an
Frauen unangenehm peinlich für die
Gesellschaft und fürs Regime jeder
Diskussion darüber wird im Keim erstickt
Fang Niemann ist schockiert wie wenige
Frauen von Hilfsangeboten wissen
es gibt viele Frauenhäuser in China aber
es werden dort nur wenige Frauen
untergebracht ein großes Problem weil
viele Frauen gar nicht wissen dass es
solche Häuser gibt
doch Chinas Gesellschaft verändert sich
Frauen stemmen sich gegen
patriarchalische familienvorstellungen
sie schließen sich zusammen und finden
Wege die staatliche Zensur zu umgehen im
Internet und auf der Straße
Frauen spielten eine ganz aktive Rolle
bei der whitepaper-bewegung viele die
damals auf die Straße gingen waren
Frauen auch später unter den
Festgenommenen waren die meisten Frauen
November 2022
hunderte demonstrierende halten leere
weiße blätterpapier in die Höhe Frauen
Männer Studierende sie protestieren
gegen Chinas strenge nullkovit-
er sind die größten Proteste gegen das
Regime seit 1989
sie alle riskieren dabei festgenommen zu
werden
[Musik]
der Grund ist dass die
pandemie-maßnahmen tiefgreifende
Auswirkungen auf die Frauen hatten
während des lockdowns ordneten die
Behörden an dass auch Frauen von zu
Hause aus arbeiten sollten
und gleichzeitig wurden die Frauen dazu
angehalten sich neben ihrem Job auch
noch um die Kinder zu kümmern
viele Frauen ertrugen diese
Doppelbelastung nicht mehr und gingen
mit Gleichgesinnten auf die Straße
auch der Mut der Whitepaper
Protestierenden führte dazu dass chinas
Führung die strengen pandemie-maßnahmen
einstellte
für die Fußballspielerinnen des infinite
Vereins hatte das Ende der
pandemiemaßnahmen gewaltige Auswirkungen
Hand in Hand weg gute Freundinnen in
China oft zusammen spazieren gehen
erzählen uns dunkelchen Ruhe und ihre
Kommilitoninnen dass sie der erste Uni
Jahrgang seit knapp drei Jahren sind der
wieder eine Abschlussfeier haben darf
voller stolz zeigen sie uns ihre Robben
ihre bachelor-urkunden und Blumen
die meisten wollen erstmal weiter an der
Uni bleiben heiraten und Kinder kriegen
ist für sie ganz weit weg
in meiner Heimat sind Sie der Meinung
dass ich längst verheiratet sein und
Kinder haben sollte aber ich will weiter
studieren ich habe gerade meinen Master
begonnen
und one been kommen aus der Provinz
Citroën und gehören der ethnischen
Minderheit der i an ihre Heimatregion
wurde erst 2020 offiziell von der Armut
befreit viele Wertvorstellungen dort
sein noch sehr traditionell
die meisten meiner Klassenkameradinnen
sind verheiratet und haben bereits zwei
oder drei Kinder
deshalb bin ich in Peking geblieben ich
will hier später auch mal arbeiten
daheim haben sie mich nicht sehr gut
verstanden
[Musik]
wie ist das Leben für Frauen in China
abseits der großen Städte wie sieht dort
ihr Alltag aus welche Träume haben Sie
unsere Reise führt uns in die Provinz
Fujian im Osten China Angst sie ist
berühmt für tiergonin ein Tee wir fragen
wo wir einen traditionellen
Familienbetrieb finden können im
nächsten Dorf sagt der Bahnwärter und
schenkt uns gleich ein paar Beutel Tee
es geht über Serpentinen den bergauf das
Dorf liegt völlig abgeschieden in einer
Scheune ist die ganze Familie versammelt
die Frauen sortieren getrocknete
Teeblätter die Männer trinken Tee wir
werden sofort auf einen Tässchen
eingeladen und dürfen bei der Arbeit
zusehen
[Musik]
die Spitzen der Teeblätter schmecken
bitter deshalb werfen wir sie weg wir
sind unter teebäumen aufgewachsen wir
sind die harte Arbeit gewohnt seit wir
Kinder sind während der t-saison ernten
wir gemeinsam von Hand und schneiden die
Blätter mit Sicheln ab
[Musik]
Chance
ihre Tochter ist acht ihr Sohn Sex jung
heiraten früh Kinder bekommen ist hier
ganz normal
bei uns auf dem Land sind die Frauen
normalerweise Hausfrauen
bei manchen Tätigkeiten die Kraft
brauchen helfen uns die Männer wenn wir
das nicht schaffen
aber in China arbeiten die meisten
Männer außer Haus und die Frauen im Haus
die Frauen kümmern sich um die Kinder
die Hausarbeit und ums kochen wir
züchten auch Hühner Enten und Schweine
und Pflanzen Gemüse an
sie muss sich jetzt weiter um den
Haushalt kümmern sagt sie ihr Schwager
Race ja u bringt uns zur Plantage der
Familie
die Waves sind seit Jahrhunderten
teefarmer
die Liebe zu Tiago an ihn wird von
Generation zu Generation weitergegeben
seit mehr als 300 Jahren
[Musik]
einmal bevor du die Blätter schüttelst
und einmal danach
der Überlieferung nach hat er von
tiguanin geträumt
danach hat er den mutterteebaum hier
gefunden
von diesem Teebaum stammen alle anderen
tiegorienbäume auf unseren Feldern
Abo
etwa 500 Kilo Tee produziert die Familie
jedes Jahr und verdient damit
umgerechnet rund 30.000 Euro ein
lukratives Geschäft
zeigt uns voller Stolz die Fabrik wie er
sie nennt hier werden die Teeblätter im
Frühling getrocknet hier müssen sie
ruhen und oxidieren danach ist der Tee
mild der Geschmack liegt zwischen grünem
und schwarzen Tee für changsjohan hat
die Fabrik noch eine andere Bedeutung
nach der Feldarbeit zünde ich hier gerne
Räucherstäbchen an
[Musik]
hier auf dem Land sein viele Frauen sehr
religiös sagt sie Gebete und Opfergaben
für die Vorfahren manchmal auch
Zigaretten fürs Jenseits
[Musik]
und dann muss sie schnell wieder zurück
zu Hause und Kindern
waysia u setzt noch mal thiagonin auf
und ich frage Changs Johan ob ihre
Tochter später auch einmal Tee
verarbeiten und verkaufen wird
unsere Arbeit ist sehr hart aber tiefe
arbeitung ist eine Tradition unserer
Vorfahren die sollten wir bewahren
für meine Kinder wünsche ich mir dass
sie zwar wissen wie man Tee herstellt
aber ich hoffe dass Sie Karriere machen
können und einmal einen besseren Job
finden
[Musik]
in ihrer Heimat ein sie sagt sie doch
mit dem wachsenden Wohlstand in China
wächst auch bei ihr der Traum von einer
besseren Zukunft für ihre Kinder die
Frauenfußball-WM wird sie sich nicht
anschauen zu viel zu tun
in Peking sind es wieder knapp 40 Grad
Turnier der frauenfußballteams es ist
fast unerträglich heiß und trotzdem
geben dunkle und die infinite
Spielerinnen alles
[Applaus]
drei der fünf Spiele verlieren sie egal
sie zählen nicht mal die Gegentore mit
genau keine Fußball spielen ist einfach
so toll um Leute kennenzulernen wir
spielen alle zusammen und haben eine
Menge Spaß so viele Mädchen das ist wie
eine große Party
[Musik]
am Ende werden die Teams geehrt es gibt
Medaillen und Trophäen für alle
und Tampons vom Sponsor
das Frauen in China heute Fußball
spielen völlig normal mit der
Gesellschaft ändern sich auch die
Trainingsmethoden
und ihre Mitspielerinnen hat der Fußball
mutiger gemacht auf und abseits des
Spielfelds
[Applaus]